نحن هنا على حدود قطاع غزه حيث يسود هدوء
اعقب عاصفه تمثلت بتبادل للقصف ما بين
الصواريخ الفلسطينيه التي انطلقت من
القطاع والغارات الاسرائيليه التي اعقبت
ذلك على عده مواقع قالت اسرائيل انها
تابعه لحركه حماس ياتي هذا التصعيد وان
كان متوقعا بعد ان قالت الفصائل بانها
سترد على ما وصفته بمجزره نابلس وفعلا هذا
ما كان وياتي ايضا تثبيتا لمعادله باتت
قائمه وهي توحيد الساحات بمعنى انفجار في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله يقود الى تصعيد على
جبهه قطاع غزه فعمليات فرديه في القدس
الشرقيه المحتله المقاتلات الاسرائيليه
ايضا لم تبرح المنطقه الجنوبيه في اطار
التاهوب السائد وفي اطار حاله تاهب على
الارض نشرت اسرائيل المزيد من بطاريات
القبه الحديديه في محيط
غزه وفي المناطق الجنوبيه الاعتقاد في
اسرائيل بان التصعيد سيتواتر عمليا وصولا
الى شهر رمضان المقبل هناك احتمال بان
تندلع مواجهه شامله في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله وكذا ايضا على حدود قطاع غزه من
حيث انفجار الحرب على هذا القطاع زياد
حلبي العربيه حدود قطاع غزه